let's have a go this I want you to pay
really close attention to how I set this
out and particularly the reasons that I
can hear all right so here's 6a I draw
the diagram you don't necessarily need
to because they do present what to you
but you will find and I've mentioned
this earlier of the year thanks boys
that a diagram is a really helpful way
of understanding question right so let's
have a go at a we're always asked to
find the unknown in these questions okay
and we are given enough information to
find out what they are so here as we
were looking isosceles triangles right I
have an isosceles triangle here I've
given two equal sides and add to find
angle this is exactly the situation we
were constructing search fantastic okay
so what you can see is equal sides here
and this side is opposite this angle and
this side is opposite this April you
really got to watch for the positions of
these sides and angles so i'm going to
say x equals 42 and i must always
provide a reason why is x 42 and the
answer is is this reason I told you hear
that equal angles our opposite equal
sides and I know that they're equal site
so I'm going to steak that in four
equals are opposite equal sides and this
is the beautiful dinner you could have
discovered right now this is true all
the time any triangle every triangle
that exists this is true okay let's have
a look at bit it has a very very subtle
difference to it looks like this it's a
38 yes
ok so here we are asked to find a leak
there's that under there the pro new
rule that we learnt in algebra that's
why I would not come on thank you for
you yeah he will be asked to find a link
instead right but the same logic applies
just in Reverse right so here I know
what the a bizarre and I can look
opposite and say well therefore the
sides have to follow suit this is really
great if I know it in one direction I
also know it in the other ok yeah two
directions anyway um so I can Satan on
this diagram y equals seven but mark is
a very very subtle difference it's not
hugely important but i want to point out
to you can you put it down do I have to
take away
I'm sure it is what's the reason for
this it's not it's not quite that equal
angles are opposite equal sides in this
case it's that equal sides because
that's what I'm finding they are
opposite equal angles and because that's
what I know right opposite equal angle
right so you can see it's the same
reason I just looking at it probably
opposite point of view okay yes um so
I'm going to recommend I think drawing
diagrams is really fantastic and the
more you do it the faster you get at it
people don't like to because next time
I'm you don't have to do it they did
provide you with a lovely diagram but
I'm drawing it so I think it's a good
idea all right last example Part C it's
the last one because it's very very
slightly different so have a look here
uh and this is this one's really worth
drawing okay so here we go oh they don't
give you any legs but they did tell you
that whatever legs are there ollie i've
got x over there ok so this is a bit
tricky because i don't have any labels
on this so i'm going to suggest
something because it'll help us in order
to talk about these different angles i'm
going to name them ok so I'm going to
make this one a and this one bear and
then this won't see this is just another
1a advantages you get if you draw a
diagram you could actually work with the
diagram and add information on it
whereas if you draw a diagram you're
just stuck with whatever they give you
and that might be okay but might be
missing helpful things so now that I've
got some labels here right I want you to
think back to the start of chapter and
last year how do we talk about angles
right how do we name an angle yeah
that's against that's right let me
remind you let me revise today man angle
you use this angle simple and then you
name the three points that formed that
ankle so for example if I want to name
this one over here right this one of the
right here corner then I've got a name
of a b c cuz cuz that's the order of the
two points that for the egg yeah um I
know this is candy maybe I just like no
sir it is it a coincidence that from
penis size 60 meters and 38 degrees is a
multiple of 738 so I guess let me see if
your question is no no all right so
having answer that question what can i
say about ABC ABC is over here right and
its opposite this side you see that they
face each other boys yeah exactly right
it's exactly right so all of these sides
are equal which means all the angles
that are opposite on the side they must
also be equal right so you can see I'll
just do what exhibit there's a [ __ ]
there and its opposite beside and here's
the angle I'm after which is opposite
aside that the same leg right so i can
say that this is equal to X degrees ok
because equal angles are opposite Igor
science ok now let me show you way up
let me show you a bit of a trick ok let
me show you a bit of a trick because
what I'm about to do is have a look at
this angle over here at single-a see be
sorry put any angle a.c b now what I'm
going to say about it is exactly the
same as what I just set up here you
don't have to repeat the reason I just
used the reason take me awhile to write
it out all you have to do is say
similarly right this is a great handy
shortcut i've used the reason i'm just
going to use it again ok w so it's equal
to x ok here's our last two lines may
watch carefully
if these angles are all equal to X that
when i add them up you taught me this
just now what's the angle sum of a
triangle yep 180 degrees okay go check
rips it quickly ok so if I've got all
those because the angles some of a
triangle is 180 degrees ok then i could
divide both sides by 3 can you see that
look look they're both equal to each
other and i can divide by 3 to get my
old son ok